особисто довгі роки намагалися
мобілізувати міжнародну спільноту щоб
завдати болючого удару по фінансових
Володимира Путіна та його оточення тепер
із початком війни в Україні це вперше
сталося запроваджено далекосячині
безпрецедентні санкції як з боку ЄС так
і з боку США але як ви думаєте чи мали
вони вплив і який
санкції виявилися абсолютно руйнівними
для Путіна та російською економіки не
можна вірити жодному слову з Росії в її
економічних звітах це відверта брехня
від російської економіки залишилося лише
тінь майже всі західні компанії пішли
близько половини резервів центробанку
заморожено майже жоден російський банк
не спроможний мати справу з західними
банками найбільш активна частина
населення виїхала з країни навряд чи
можна розробляти щось із тих промтоварів
що випускалися раніше через відсутність
деталей Це повна економічна катастрофа
тож усіх то кажуть що санкції не
працюють жертви російської пропаганди
санкції працюють щоправда у санкційному
режимі досі є безліч на зівок перша та
найважливіша в тому що Ми продовжуємо
купувати російські нафту та газ тобто
продовжуємо платити їм сотні мільйонів
якщо не мільярд доларів на день доки ми
не припинемо це робити у Путіна буде
достатньо коштів для фінансування війни
та вбивства українців ми маємо знайти
спосіб це зупинити ці нових обмежень та
подібних заходів які вже походженні
недостатньо необхідно повністю зупинити
приплив грошей до Росії а це означає
припинити закупівлю нафти та газу
як захід має це зробити
по-перше на Росії потрібно просто
накласти ембаргом просто накласти не
ходити навколо крім того необхідно
запровадити ембаргу щодо країни які нині
не підтримують санкції треба сказати
якщо вас бізнес із Росією ми з вами не
матимемо жодних справ потрібно бути
твердими якщо ми не будемо жорсткими то
війна буде дуже довгою і створить нам у
майбутньому набагато більше проблем
тобто йдеться не лише про країни заходу
але також про Китай та Індію які
продовжують вести бізнес із Росією
продовжують купувати нафту вони не є
частиною режиму санкцій як бути з ними
що згадаю почати можна з країн трохи
менших от Туреччиною вона щодня обходить
санкції на користь Росії це не
найсильніша країна Вони мають ослабку
економіку і їм треба сказати
Дотримуйтесь правил піде на Африка
об'єднання Арабські Емірати Індонезія є
чимало країн які продовжують вести
відносини з Росією та не є економічними
наддержавами отже є важелі які змусять
їх бути з нами ми цього ще не
використовували А треба
хотілося б ще запитати про роль західних
країн ви багато писали Про президента
Путіна та його фінансистів Ви писали
проросійських олігархів про схеми
завдяки яким вони тримають свої гроші в
багатьох західних столицях Як ви
вважаєте чи достатньо західні країни
такі скажімо як Швейцарія чи
Великобританія зробили для того щоб
справді обмежити та зупинити Цей потік
Я думаю Швейцарія точно зробила
недостатньо вона залишається чимось
подібним до отих Гавані для брудних
російських грошей за даними асоціації
швейцарських банкірів понад 200
мільярдів доларів із Росії перебувають у
швейцарській банках і наскільки мені
відомо лише близько семи з них було
заморожено А чому на заморожену решту
193 мені відомо також що швейцарська
Влада активно співпрацює з російським
криміналітетом ми мали ситуацію коли 20
мільйонів доларів було заморожено через
зв'язок з російськими бандитами
причетними до вбивства мого адвоката
Сергія магніцького а й швейцарський уряд
близько 80% цих коштів повертає
російським злочинцям
І чому ж тому що вони мають
контурпродуктивну систему але там завжди
було так чому Вони приймали золото
нацистів і таке інше Це історія
Швейцарія брудна країна в тому що
стосується російських грошей і вони не
намагаються нічого виправити у цьому є
велика проблема
А як ви думаєте ось ви говорили про те
що російські олігархи мають мільярди в
західних столицях на вашу думку санкції
їх зачепили було багато повідомлень про
арешт вілли на півдні Франція або яхти
але як ви думаєте ми все ще борсуємося
на мілководі чи вже дійшли до суті
точно вдарили по олігархах внесені до
списку санкцій повністю порушує людині
життя не відкритий рахунок у банку чи не
випустити кредитну картку не отримати
візу до більшості країн гарного мало цю
олігархи більшість із них майже всі
заробили свої гроші нечесним шляхом і
вони завжди знали що колись за їхніми
грошима прийдуть і тому вони
використовують різні схеми та різних
людей це підставні особи родичі тощо і
таким чином на кожного олігарха припадає
цілу групу осіб які допомагають йому
уникати санкції і тому наступний крок у
всі ці програмі західних санкцій
переслідувати тих хто всіляко допомагає
йому уника ти санкції це справді важлива
частина майбутніх суворих заходів проти
Путіна його олігархів Та посібників
ви маєте на увазі західних аудиторів
юристів банкірів
банкірів юрист і агентів з нерухомості
членів сімей Трастові компанії всіх хто
допомагав олігархам продовжувати Жити
приспівуючи після потрапляння до списку
санкцій
було чимало дебатів щодо заморожених
російських активів та їх використання
для відновлення України потім чи зараз
скажімо для допомоги внутрішньо
приміщеним особам в Україні пише Це
юридично складне питання Думки щодо
цього розділилися А що ви думаєте з
цього приводу
сперечатися взагалі нема про що Путін
завдав Україні збитків у розмірі понад
трильйон доларів ми заморозили 350
мільярдів доларів резерву центробанку
росії Путін все зруйнував Він має це
виправити проблема в тому що ці гроші
належать Росії і вони захищені тим що
називаються суверенним імунітетом це
означає що ви не можете чіпати їх
посольстві не можете чіпати резерви
центробанку отже Путін порушує
міжнародні норми вторгається вбиває
руйнує а потім його захищає міжнародне
право
що необхідно Так це внесення поправок до
міжнародного права щоб враховувати
злочини
у глобальному масштабі і тут взагалі
нема про що сперечатися питання має бути
лише в тому як швидко ми збираємося
внести зміни до закону про суверенний
імунітет щоб гроші могли бути
конфісковані та використані на допомогу
постраждалим в Україні
мої питання у тому чи є у заморожуванні
цих грошей Який сенс На жаль ми бачимо
як президент Путін продовжує війну в
Україні вона продовжується і вже другий
рік поспіль немає жодних ознак того що
Кремль змінить курс заморожування цих
грошей справді допоможе чи зупиниться
війну
заморожування грошей само собою не
зупинить війну але треба розуміти що
якщо в Росії закінчився боєприпаси то
даємо взяти нові треба витрачати гроші
якщо позбавити їх грошей то їм не купити
стільки боєприпасів Отже ідея в тому що
позбавити їх фінансових ресурсів для
цього й тільки тому що ми говоримо що ж
він продовжує цю війну Він можливо
використовує ресурси призначені для
виплати пенсій ми не знаємо звідки в
нього гроші але що ми точно знаємо то це
те що гроші потрібні для війни якщо ми
зможемо перекрити доступ до грошей то
сподіваюся у якісь момент ми зможемо
перекрити йому можливість вести війну
і перехо до війни варто поговорити чим
це все може закінчитися Отже ви особисто
знайомі з президентом Путіним ніхто не
знає що він думає Але що на вашу думку є
для нього кінцевою метою яким ви бачите
розвиток подій чим це може закінчитися
я добре знаю як Путін поводиться тому що
боровся з ним 13 років він ніколи не йде
на компроміс ніколи не відступає і не
веде переговори
він здатний лише на ескалацію тому
щоразу коли ми думаємо що він зазнав
десь поразки він просто множить свою
перевагу
тож є лише два варіанти завершення цієї
війни або Він переможе в Україні і тоді
гарантую вам рушить на інші країни
або перемогу українців які виженуть у
російські солдатів зі своєї території і
тоді Путіну ймовірно втратить і Владу і
життя
тобто єдиний вихід із цього перемога
України
єдине вихід для України - Це її повна
перемога та повна поразка Росії треба
щоб Росія програла щоб це було всім
видно і якщо так буде ми матимемо
можливість рухатися до мирного
майбутнього в Європі якщо цього не
станеться то у нас будуть великі
неприємності